GBBO S08E01
Can you see it, Noel?
I can't see it anywhere.
Big white tent, 12 new bakers.
Sorry, Sue, you did say
white tent, didn't you?
Where are they, Prue?
Dunno. They're late.
Maybe we should've
got a minicab?  Hmm.
My daughter applied for me.
This is who I've got
to thank for all this.
My mum said I'm already a winner.
That's such a mum thing to say.
When I saw the tent, my heart
rate went through the roof.
It's like my wedding day, all over
again, except my wife is not here.
I'm going to be baking in the tent.
It's got so much history.
Are you sure I'm not asleep?
Are you sure it's happening?
Initially, I thought it
was a bit of a fluke!
I'm not going to lie.
I don't think I'll believe
it until I see it on telly.
I'm ready to go.
12 new bakers...
My children said,
"Don't get sent home first."
If I do, I'm not allowed home.
NOEL:  30 brand-new challenges,
set by Paul Hollywood
and our new judge, Prue Leith.
This year is going
to be very special.
The bakers may think they know what
I want, but, when it comes to Prue,
they've absolutely no idea.
Prue's got 50 years' experience
in the business.
She'll know what she wants.
I'll be firm but fair,
because I want the bakers
to do their very best.
Baking is such a treat,
but it has to be the very best and
it has to be worth the calories.
I am always getting frustrated
with myself.
I cannot tell you the amount of
cakes I've thrown away,
biscuits I've thrown away.
Technical bakes may unstitch
me. We'll see.
NOEL:  In 2017, who will win
The Great British Bake Off?
I am British, but I'm
a proud Scotsman.
So, it would be good to be the first
Scottish Bake Off winner.
I just want to get on with it now
and, erm, burn that first cake.
NOEL:  We're back at the home
of the Bake Off,
Welford Park in Berkshire.
Right, so, I've got a list
of what we have to do.
First, set up theme of the week.
I was thinking a semaine of genoise,
creme patissiere, fraisiers gateaux.
Oh, I love it. What's it mean?
It's cake week.
I'm so excited. We're actually going
to walk into the tent
for the first time.  I know.
I'm a little bit nervous.
I-I don't really do camping.
Yeah, I don't think we
have to sleep in there.
Oh, OK.
NOEL:  Over the next two days, the
bakers will face three challenges,
after which, one of them will be
named our first Star Baker,
and another will be asked to
leave the Bake Off tent.
Hello, bakers and welcome to
the fabulous Bake Off tent.
We're all newbies here, well,
apart from ol' blue eyes.
So, let's get baking with your
very first Signature Challenge.
The judges would love you to make
a family sized fruity cake.
Now, the choice of sponge and,
indeed, fruit is entirely up to you
but it must be fresh fruit.
No dried fruit allowed.
Basically, what we're saying
is if it was a fruit party,
sultanas would not be
on the guest list.
You have two hours to
make your fruity cake.
Do you want to do it?
Shall we do it together?
BOTH: On your marks.
Get set. Bake!
Plain flour.
The reason why the fruity cake
challenge is such a great signature
to start off the series with
is because it really tests
the bakers' knowledge
of baking in its purest form.
How much moisture is that
fruit going to release?
What that does is make the inside
of the cake quite soggy,
so what's difficult to judge
is when it's baked properly.
When you stick a skewer in
to see if the cake is done,
the skewer may well come out wet
because it's hit a piece
of fresh fruit,
and you will be fooled into thinking
that the cake isn't done.
It's not a very easy
start to Bake Off.
Morning. How are you doing?  Hello,
James.  Good to see you all.
Tell us what you're doing.
So, I'm making a rhubarb,
orange and ginger cake and it's
got a crumble topping as well.
Takes me back to my childhood where
we used to have rhubarb crumbles
on a Sunday lunchtime.
That looks like proper rhubarb
out of a garden.
It is. Picked fresh from my
allotment, yeah.
Oh, how fantastic.  So, my dad
is the magpie of rhubarb.
Every time I go up the allotment,
he's nicked someone else's chunk of
rhubarb and he keeps growing it,
so he's...  Do the rest of the
allotment know that, James?
Oh, shh, don't tell anyone.
They do now!
Married dad of two,
James is a finance manager
from Brentwood in Essex.
He's been baking and gardening with
his dad, Brian, since he was five.
Put your back into it. Anyone would
think you're getting old.
His signature fruity
cake has a whopping 600g
of rhubarb in the sponge.
How are you cooking the rhubarb?
It's all going to be mixed in raw.
It'll cook for about an hour,
so it should soften up nicely.
It should be a little squashy.
Yeah, it does get a little...
juicy, shall we say.
Don't give too much away, James!
Oh, yeah. The judges are here.
NOEL:  For the first challenge of
this year's Great British Bake Off,
four of our new bakers have chosen
a great British ingredient.
Apple.
My grandma, she used to make
really good apple cake.
I used to call her Buzz, cos she
had a hearing aid that buzzed.
And I always used to call her,
every so often, Granny Smith.
I decided to name it after her.
Better than calling it buzz-cake!
NOEL:  Stacey lives in Hertfordshire,
with her husband, James, and
is a stay-at-home mum to her sons
Max, Zane, and Ethan.
Thank you. A pleasure.
THE OTHERS LAUGH
NOEL:  Her apple and walnut cake
contains five large Granny Smiths.
There's an awful lot
of apples in this.
Got to make sure that they're
all blended in nicely.
I'm making an apple crumble cake.
It's inspired by my sister's
lack of a sweet tooth.
This is for you, sister.
Liam is a student from
Hackney in east London.
At 19, he's this year's
youngest baker,
but he's already passing on
his skills to his nephews,
Chamari and Lakwan.
Happy?
His crumble-topped apple
loaf cake is lightly spiced
with nutmeg and cinnamon.
Why did you choose a loaf tin
and not a shallower tin?
It makes the baking more difficult.
But I like loaves.
That's bread.  You like
the shape of it?
It's not... Yeah, I like
the shape of loaves.
Liam, just say it's
always been perfect.
Flake of almonds, icing sugar, done.
And "done" - I like that!
Liam, I love the confidence.
Thank you.  It's terrific.
NOEL:  One Signature Bake is the
product of a weekend in Amsterdam,
resulting in an unusual
choice of fruit.
As I do, I go around all
the bakeries possible,
and there was some
lemon and courgette
and I fell in love with it.
And, technically, everything that's
got seeds in, is a fruit.
NOEL:  Russian-born Julia
lives in West Sussex
and bakes while Skyping her nan
back in her hometown
of Kemerovo, Siberia.
Her cake will also be filled with
blueberries and lemon curd
but there's already a problem
with her courgettes.
I meant to squeeze my courgettes
before I put them in.
I would keep that quiet.  Yeah.
How do you squeeze the moisture
out of a courgette?
Basically, you just put it
in...  Do you just wring it?
Basically, you have to grate it
first, and put it in a tea towel,
and squeeze it.  OK.  But...
So, you do know how to do it, you
just forgot?  I do know.
Just deny it. If they say, "Have you
not squeezed the moisture out of
"this courgette?" Yeah, I have.
Say, "Of course I have."
I'm just not strong enough.
Elsewhere in the tent,
there has been squeezing.
I'm not doing too crazy.
I don't want to squash it.
Sophie is a former Army officer
from West Molesey in Surrey.
She'll sandwich her squeezed
pineapple and coconut sponges
with coconut Italian
meringue buttercream.
I just want to avoid too much
leakage into the batter.
Done it without before, it was fine.
It's just a precaution, really.
NOEL:  She's not the only baker
that's headed for the tropics.
I'm making a coconut cake.
My wife and my daughter love it,
but my son doesn't like anything
with bits inside it.
NOEL:  Peter is an IT manager
and bakes every Sunday
for his local church
in Southend-on-Sea.
That looks awesome.
NOEL:  As well as fresh coconut,
he's using coconut flour,
coconut milk, and coconut sugar.
I don't think you can ever
get enough coconut,
unless the cake screams,
"Oh, leave me.
"I've had enough coconut.
I'm tired!"
HE LAUGHS
NOEL:  And we have a third
fruity cake castaway.
I'm making a mango and
pineapple sponge.
Good for us, really, isn't
it, all this fruit?
NOEL:  Chris is a software engineer
from Somerset.
He's used a spreadsheet to calculate
the perfect balance
of mango and pineapple
in his unique sponge.
There's no butter in it and
there's...  No butter?
No butter at all.  No oil,
no marg, no butter?
Correct. Nothing at all.
How many eggs?  Just two.
Two?  Mm. Cook for 33 minutes.
You must have a tremendous amount
of fruit in there, then.
Yes, because the whole point
is that we can taste it.
Yeah, solid.
Going to put it in the oven.
I wonder if there's a countdown
clock anywhere.
I'm not sure how quickly
it's going to bake.
I'm just making sure I've
got an even amount in both tins.
You've got to be precise
on the Bake Off.
Mwah.  It's going in at
160, for 45 minutes.
TIMERS BEEP
Calm.
Cross my fingers.
And start.
We'll see how it goes.
Bakers, you've got one hour
left on your fruity cakes.
How long is your cake going
to be in the oven for?
It could to be up to 75 minutes.
I'm hoping an hour.  Yeah,
that's the same with me.
NOEL:  The baking time for a fruity
cake can be a complete mystery.
The longer you look at
it, the more it cooks.
NOEL:  As the temperature in
the sponge rises,
it's hard to tell how much moisture
the fruit will release...
..and how long the wetter batter
will take to bake.
SHE HUMS
Oh, God. It isn't baking
the way I feel it should be.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
No, your... Your red light's
got to be on.
Oh, for crying out loud!
Because if the light's not
on, the oven's not on.  OK.
Thank you, Stacey!
I had it written on my hand.
"Make sure the oven's on."
Yan is a biomedical
scientist for the NHS
and spends her weekends
playing football
in her hometown of Enfield
in north London.
Yes!
Her team-mates' favourite apple
and cinnamon cake has a crumble
topping drizzled in caramel.
It was sitting in residual heat,
so, the crumble's gone all soft.
It's just a puddle of fat.
Let's make this again.
Luckily, I've got apples
and crumble...
..as a contingency.
NOEL:  While Yan has to
start all over again...
Oh!
..Flo has moved on to her
fillings and decorations.
It's, erm, a citrus cake and I'm
doing a lemon curd filling.
Is that a "lemon caird" filling?
Lemon... Lemon curd!
ALL LAUGH
Stop it!  I'll be a translator.
It's good you've got a
friend now.  Stop it!
NOEL:  Grandmother Flo,
from Liverpool,
sometimes helps out at
her son's restaurant,
but gets most enjoyment
baking for her family.
Why don't I get invited to
your houses for a meal?
I ain't got one.  Cos you're
the best at it.
NOEL:  Her children had to help
her type up her recipe
for a triple-layered citrus cake,
filled with fresh oranges
and lemons.
Me daughter put little messages
on the bottom of it.
"Well done, Mum!" Aw!
"We love you!"
I'm nervous as anything.  Are
you? Oh, don't be nervous.
Nothing to worry about it.
I can always ask you to help me,
can't I?  Yeah.
I'll say no!  I know!  But you
could always ask.  I know.
While making a second sponge
has cost Yan valuable time...
..Tom is spending precious minutes
giving his fruity cake
an expensive makeover.
I wouldn't want to just put
a pear on the top of a cake.
Tom is an architect and
sports fanatic from Edinburgh.
Yes!
His golden pear will top a triple
tiered pear and blackberry cake.
It's just going to be mottled,
rustic effect.
It's not the sort of thing
I do very often.
Tom's gilded pear will
have some stiff competition.
I've got me little cut-out pattern,
erm, so, I'm going to put it
over the top of the cake,
and then I'm going to use
freeze dried strawberries,
and then do, like,
a fresh fruit garnish round it.
So, you made that yourself?
It took ages.
NOEL:  Kate is a health
and safety inspector
and a keen amateur blacksmith
from Knowsley, Merseyside.
Her intricate, stencilled
finish will top
three layers of strawberry
and rose sponge.
I love the combination
of rose and strawberry.
How are you going to make sure that
one doesn't dominate the other?
Hopefully, I'm going to layer it
with some
strawberries going through.
Well, good luck.
Thank you.  Thank you.
When it comes to fillings
and decorations...
Mm. I don't know what he's doing,
but I want to dip my finger in it.
..Stephen is going further
than anyone else.
Toffee sauce. Then, after
that, we're going to
crystallise the citrus rind.
I'm going to mix up the mascarpone,
cinnamon, and icing sugar,
and then, erm...
I probably should read my
instructions really, shouldn't I?
Stephen is a marketing
executive from Watford.
His mum, Judy, began teaching
him to bake when he was three.
Are you in ounces?
Yes!  What year is this?
For his Bonfire Night apple cake,
he's planning a spectacular
final flourish,
straight from his mum's recipe book.
What's happening here?  So,
it's...  It's like some
bizarre game of chess.
I love it.  Every Bonfire Night,
Mum would make us toffee apples.
So, these are done by taking a melon
baller, small piece of apple,
dip the toffee, hang them upside
down. They'll leave a trail of
toffee, which, when turned the
right way up, will look like
the flames of a fire.  Oh, wow.
Yeah, I know. Amazing.
I think I'm in love with you.
Of course, if it doesn't work...
Already?
Bong!
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left
to make your fruity cakes.
Does the pan not make
a noise? Is it...
DULL BONG
Oh, yes, you are better.
It's always a tricky one,
whether to open it or not.
Let's do it. Let's be brave.
Testing the bake
on a fruity cake...
It's all very serious
and quiet in here, now.
..can be a total lottery.
Kind of Russian roulette
of rhubarb.
You don't want to mistake, like,
the juice from the apple
for underbaked sponge.
Just one sec, sorry. I think
that's apple on the skewer.
Okey dokey.
NOEL:  Whilst those making sandwich
cakes with separate sponges...
We're all good.  ..should
need less baking time...
Oh, look at them babies.
..for those baking one large cake...
Absolutely nowhere near ready.
..this first Signature Challenge...
Cheers!  ..is about
to get even harder.
You've got no cake, there, have you?
Hm?  You've got no cake, there?  Yeah,
I don't, it's just apple, isn't it?
It's supposed to be out in four
minutes. Not a chance in hell.
I shouldn't have gone for a loaf!
There's nothing I can do now.
Should've just went for a sandwich.
Pants.
TIMER BEEPS
OK, there's the magic bleep.
It's just a sponge.
No-one's going to die.
Oh!  Unless the bakers have
left enough remaining time
for their cakes to cool...
I'm not panicking. It's all good.
..they won't be able to fill or
decorate them in time for judging.
Nearly done, that.
What's your problem, that you
need these to cool down?  Yeah.
You never know, I might
go on the first one.  No.
Think you're going to be all right?
Deep breaths.  So, what do you think
about your new job?
HE LAUGHS
I don't think I'm going
to be all right.
I think you're going to be fine.
I think we should swap.  No, no.
I think you'll be around.
15 minutes to go.
I'm going to turn the oven up.
Come on.
Oh, nice.
SHE SIGHS
Not too shabby.
Crystallised oranges to
go on top of the cake.
Just grind up the freeze-dried
strawberry pieces into
a really fine powder.
Oh!
HE SIGHS
My heart's going now.
They're nice and crispy.
They'll have to go on.
All's I've got to do is decorate
the top, and then I'll be fine.
Has anyone got a small
sieve I could borrow?
My God. Thank you very much.
Fingers crossed this works.
Right, that'll do.
That's as good as it'll get.
Are you finished?  Yeah.
You?  Ah.
Right, bakers, you have two minutes
to bring this to a fruity
conclusion,
and, you know, who
doesn't want that?
I don't think I'm going to
get my apples done in time.
SHE SIGHS
Fingers crossed.
I just pray that it's baked.
Oh.  I haven't got time
to muck about.
Come on.
Shizzle is nizzling.
Oh, no!
I've lost some bottom.
What do you need, mate?
Do you need icing sugar?
That's it.
Yeah.  Let's wipe down.  OK. All
right. Whisk, whisk, whisk.
If I tuck it under,
don't tell anyone.
Bakers, you've got one minute.
There there's just so much
moisture out of the rhubarb.
You're good?  Yeah, solid.
Dripping all over the place.
Bakers, your time's up.
Looks gorgeous.
Your first challenge is over.
Well done.
HE LAUGHS
Can I just, like...  No, it's fine.
Don't touch it.
Like, the middle, though...  Don't
touch it! Don't touch it! Liam!
I've made such a mess.
I'm so sorry.  Oh, my God!
Look at the state of this place!
The bakers will now face
the judgment of Prue and Paul
for the very first time.
Hello.  Hiya.
I think you've lost
a little bit of the stencil.
I always have a slight problem
with things you're not going to eat.
Nobody's going to eat a marigold.
My favourite bit.  Oh, God!
Or perhaps it's not!
Is that all right?
It tasted like a clown's nose.
The cake is all rose water.
It's not what we wanted
in a FRUITY cake.
It's a rose cake.
Style above substance.
How much baking powder
did you put in there?
Five teaspoons.
Yeah, it's burning my tongue.
Before the baking powder hits you,
you get a really nice, yes,
coconut flavour.
If somebody said to me
you're going to put a whole pear
on top of the cake,
I would have said,
"No, that's silly" -
but it actually looks very striking.
I think you have overbaked
the cakes, for sure.
It's a little bit heavy.  I meant to
squeeze a bit of juice out of it,
and then I forgot.  You forgot.
Well, you're a nice, honest girl.
I told you not to tell them!
I couldn't lie!
I think it looks great.
It looks well-baked.
I love the candied fruit on top
of that.
You finished quite early,
didn't you?
I did, yeah.  You were sitting there.
I kicked myself.  Why?
I left the lemon curd in the fridge.
Lemon curd in the fridge?  Yeah.
OK. Let's have a look.
Here we go. Oh, dear!
Mm! That is good sponge.
Loads of orange flavour
coming through.  Oh, good.
Do you know? I think there's
enough citrus in there.
Lemon curd is lovely, but unless
you are very restrained about it,
and only put the thinnest layer,
it would have been overpowering.
It's nice, that, Flo.
I'm awful pleased.
It's a shame about the lemon curd.
I have never heard of a sponge cake
with no fat in it,
with only two eggs.
I think your sponge is baked
to perfection.
Well, I tell you what.
It's got flavour. Texture,
not right in the middle,
because it all got squashed.  OK.
It is a bit stodgy.
It's a bit boring.  Oh, God.
I'm not getting a huge amount
of flavour through.
I'm getting the sponge
and I'm getting an apple.
Not light as air,
but it is a good sponge.
I think you got away with it,
considering that was your
second one, as well.
I'll take that as a win.
THEY LAUGH
Maybe a draw.  Yeah.
It looks absolutely delicious.
Thank you.
I love the sunflower flames,
and the shine of the toffee
is perfect.
Beautifully baked.  Thank you.
To get that texture of apple,
which is just slightly soft,
and you have those gorgeous warming
spices coming through.
The combination of flavours
is perfect.
I mean, it's just like
a little sum-up of autumn.
Thank you.
Very well thought through.
Well done. Well done.
Very good.  Oh, wow.  Thank you.
WHISPERS:  Nailed it!
Well done.  Thank you.
It looks as if the apple
has sunk a little.
The bake's OK,
but I get a hint of cinnamon.
I'm not convinced that
the whole thing together works.
I think it does look
a little bit rustic.
It's just mud.  Wet in the middle.
It's been flooded with water all the
time.  Yeah.
..while it's in the oven.
Nothing that a lot of custard
wouldn't help.
It's very neat. The piping's good.
Oh, look at that sponge.
I think that texture's lovely.
Pineapple flavour
comes walloping through.
You must have dried the pineapple
a bit, did you?  Yes. Yeah, yeah.
That's delicious.
I mean, it really is.
Oh, my gosh, wow.  The pineapple that
comes through there is delicious,
and that silkiness that comes
from the Italian meringue,
it just works so well with that.
Wow. Thank you so much.
I'll have another piece of that.
No, you can't.  Well done.  Thank you.
Gosh!
When he sort of...
I was like, "No! It can't be!"
I am worried I might have peaked
a bit too soon.
When he put his hand out,
I thought he was going to hit me.
I know it's not pretty, but I was
hoping that it would hit the spot.
It's the Peter Beardsley of cakes.
Oh, my... Agh!
The Bakers were able to practise
for the first challenge.
Every week, their second
will be a gingham-clad mystery.
Bakers! Now it's time for
your first Technical Challenge.
Today, set for you
by the lovely Prue.
Prue, any advice to the Bakers?
Well, all I can say
is it's a bit fiddly.
Right. As this challenge
is judged blind,
I'm going to have to ask
these guys to go.
No, not you.  What? I just wanted
to see where they go.
No, we've got work to do.  OK.
We have to set the very first
Technical Challenge,
which today involves Prue wanting
you to make 12 chocolate mini rolls.
That's 144
of these childhood favourites,
each one of which needs to have
a delicate chocolate sponge,
a swirl of peppermint buttercream,
and covered in chocolate -
but, cheekily, do not worry
about leaving a bare bottom.
You have two hours.
On your marks.  Get set.
Bake!
Oh, my God!
To make the chocolate mini rolls,
the bakers have all been given
the same ingredients,
from Prue's pared down recipe.
The instructions are vague,
a bit like me.
I've made a Swiss roll a couple
of weeks ago, so to me,
it's just lots of little
Swiss rolls.
I've never made a mini roll ever
in my life, why would you?
Prue, why have you chosen
chocolate mini rolls?
They are very familiar to everybody,
so they seem like an easy cake.
In fact, they are
very difficult to do.
They must look identical and neat.
Inside, soft chocolate sponge -
because there's no flour in it,
there is no baking powder.
You are relying entirely on the
egg whites to rise the sponge -
and there is peppermint buttercream,
which if you put too much essence
in, it tastes like toothpaste -
and it must make a perfect swirl.
Altogether, not an easy task.
That's delicious to eat -
very chocolaty sponge,
with that flavour of peppermint,
but not too much.
Let's see what they're made of -
and all I can say is I have
more difficult challenges to come.
Charming.
The recipe is telling me that I
have to...  Make a paste with cocoa,
butter...  One teaspoonful
of vanilla extract.
Four tablespoons of water.
It's looking like it should be
the right consistency.
My first bake wasn't brilliant,
so I need to pull it back a bit
with this one.
And then the next instruction,
whisk the egg yolks
with two thirds of the sugar.
SHE WARBLES HER TONGUE
And then mix egg yolks
with the paste.
Lovely jubbly.  Whisk the egg whites
with the remaining sugar.
This is getting enough air into the
egg whites
to give it a really nice,
light texture.
That'll do.
Gently folding in.
Nice and smooth,
but still plenty of body.
Cos the egg is the only raising
agent in this.
If you miss that step out, then
I think you could be in trouble.
Whisk in the egg whites
to the remaining sugar.
How are you feeling
after the first one?
Nah. So if I come in table for this,
it should be all right.
Going in.  Go.
Big breath. Big breath.
Here goes.
It says 12-20,
but that's pretty vague.
I don't know, I don't know.
I'm going to do 12 minutes,
cos as soon as they lose
that moisture,
they'll just crack as they roll.
See you in 12.
This isn't right.
You see, this isn't right...
and I can't work out
what I'm not doing right, actually.
Maybe it's supposed to be like that.
What's next?
Got to make the buttercream.
Is that something
you've done before?  I'm joking!
You're still joking, that's good!
Yeah, but joking can only
get you so far.
Thanks a lot!
It doesn't say how
much peppermint essence to put in.
Start off by doing
a quarter of a teaspoon.
I just put in a...
and then I'll see.
The flavour is not too overpowering.
It needs a bit more.
It doesn't taste like toothpaste.
Bakers, you are halfway through
the making of your mini marvels.
I just want to get to the point
where they are quite flexible.
They don't look done at all.
Any time soon.
Slightly sinking in one bit.
Let's be done, guys.
I don't know if I should
do it again or not.
Flat as a pancake.
So, I've started again.
I'm starting again as well.
Nothing like a bit of stress.
OK...
It's a little bit rubbery.
I want to redo my sponges.
I think I didn't
fold it in very well, maybe.
That looks disgusting, doesn't it?
Do think I need to mix it
for a bit longer?
Try not to lose the air.
Yep. Quite happy with those.
Second time lucky.
Melt the plain
and milk chocolate together.
Got dark and milk chocolate in here.
It'll be nice.
It's a chocolate feast!
That is pure...
Wow. I can actually feel my hips
widening as we do it.
Is that good?  Well, it's a thing.
OK.  And the white chocolate
is presumably drizzled over?
I made a mistake.
I've put white chocolates
in the milk chocolate.
See if I can do something with it.
See you again in 12 minutes.
You've got half an hour left
on your mini rolls.
Here.
He's bowled over.
Spread the filling
over the cool sponges.
I've got to make sure there's
even spreading of the buttercream.
Make sure I get right to the edges,
I want the nice tight curl.
OK, so... Roll from each short
so that it meets in the middle.
Roll it like that.
Roll it the other way.
And then cut that in half,
and then do the same thing
with the other one.
I've just scored it a little bit
to try and get it nice and tight.
Using the piece of paper to help me.
Just making sure
that the roll is tight.
It is fiddly.
It's all sticking.
I didn't realise that it would be
this much pressure.
Relief!
Happier with the rise on these.
They are looking absolutely awful.
Cut into 12 mini rolls.
The length is 20cm.
That doesn't divide.
But the edges are not neat,
so take a centimetre off each side,
and it works out, 6cm each.
Hopefully, you'll have
a perfect little spiral
and it'll be nice and tight.
HE LAUGHS
Oh, well. Put those ones
to the bottom.
They've got a nice whirl inside,
so at least that's something.
Ooh, didn't cut it even.
Right. Here we go.
It just says, "Cover the rolls,
leaving the bases uncovered."
How are you going to pour
your chocolate?
Are you going to pour it on,
or are you going to dip it?
Because we are allowed an exposed
bottom, I will just pour it all on.
If there's an opportunity
to keep the bottom exposed,
we should all embrace that.
I'm planning on taking
my trousers off,
and Paul and Prue do the judging.
Just trying to ladle it over.
How long have you got left?
You tell them five minutes,
cos I don't want to make them
stressed, but you can.
OK, bakers,
you've got five minutes left.
What he said.
Use the white chocolate
to decorate it
in some unspecified way.
I'm thinking quite simple,
just some sort of lines.
Oh, shaky hands!
I don't have any time.
WHISPERS:  This is dangerous.
Looks are deceiving, aren't they?
My hands are shaking so much.
Oh, God.
Such a mess.
OK, bakers, your time is up.
Please bring
your mini chocolate rolls up
and put them behind your photo.
Paul and Prue are expecting
12 identical mini rolls
filled with a perfect swirl
of delicately flavoured
peppermint buttercream -
and they'll have no idea
whose is whose.
THUNDER RUMBLES
Oh, my God, I'm all shaky.
Hm.  Should we start from this side?
It's not perfect.
There is white chocolate on the top,
and they're all fairly even in size.
Yes.
Let's have a look.
It's got a proper swirl.
The sponge is good.  The peppermint
is a little bit strong.  Mm.
This is certainly rougher.
They haven't been cut properly.
Very nice swirl.
That sponge looks good.
Good.  The peppermint is good
in that one.
It's a shame they look
the way they do.
I know, because
it's really good inside.
They're quite small,
so there should be a good swirl.
Look at that.  Interesting.
The sponge is actually
not very spongy.
It's just more like a ganache
than a sponge.  Yeah.
These look a little bit messy.
But I quite like the feathering.
Needed a bit longer in the oven,
that one, I think.
This one's decided to use
a different colour of chocolate.
We did ask for white chocolate.
Not getting the peppermint
in that one.  No.
Very neat,
and the chocolate is very good.
Nice swirl. Got a bit
of a hit of peppermint.
The sponge is nice, as well.
I think this is a very good one.
Right, moving on to this.
This is art. This is definitely art.
I rather like it.
Not much of a swirl,
this is a sort of C.
Too much mint.
Now these are actually quite neat.
I like the white chocolate
on the top.
Nicely coated, as well.
All the same size.  Let's have a look
and see what it is like inside.
Oh, dear.  Solid bit of cream,
no swirl.
That is a shame.
This is not a pretty sight.
The ends haven't been covered,
the white chocolate has been blobbed
on the top from about ten foot,
I reckon. Interesting swirl.
The sponge has not been cooked
enough,
so it's very squashed and thin.
These look neater. Equal in size.
There is a little bit of a swirl
in there.
The sponge is very good.
This looks quite neat, as well.
Mostly the same size.
Not too much of a swirl.
For me, there's a little bit
too much mint.
Sort of feathered.
Chunky monkeys, aren't they?
We're looking for more of a swirl
in the peppermint.
The sponge isn't too bad at all.  No.
It looks a little denser than it is.
THUNDER RUMBLES
Prue and Paul have made
their decision.
In 12th place is...this one.
Whose is this?  They might be mine.
Right. They were still raw.
This one is number 11.
Stacey. Your sponge mixture
wasn't cooked properly.
In tenth place is this one.
Why have we got a milk chocolate
on the top, not white?
It was just a mistake.
Flo is ninth. Liam, eighth.
Tom, seventh. Stephen, sixth.
Sophie, fifth. And Yan is forth.
And third place we have this one.
Very well done, Julia.
Lovely swirl. Excellent.
And in second place...is this one.
Whose is this? Well done.
Thank you.  Very neat,
love the white lines on the top.
Thank you.  So, in the first place,
it has to be Kate.
They're all the same size,
swirl is there,
the peppermint flavour
is finely balanced, well done.
Thank you.
Well done!
Happier than this morning.
Do you know what?
I don't mind mini rolls,
but I don't think I'll ever make
a rose cake ever again!
I don't think anyone has any idea
quite what the tent
does to you in there.
I don't want to be out week one.
That would be absolutely gutting.
Definitely not.
Stern talking to myself tonight.
Serious talks.
One challenge remaining
before someone is crowned
this year's first Star Baker
and another is the first to leave
the Bake Off tent.
Bakers, welcome back to your first
Showstopper Challenge.
Today, Prue and Paul would love you
to make an illusion cake,
a cake designed to trick the eye
into thinking
it's anything but a cake.
It has to have the same flavour
of sponge throughout,
and the size and shape
must be to scale.
So maybe don't make
a woolly mammoth.
Yes, pace yourselves,
maybe not week one.
All the decoration
needs to be edible,
and you've got four hours to create
your spectacular show-stopping
illusions.
On your marks...  Get set...  Bake!
Making a cake that doesn't look like
a cake is the most complex
Showstopper Challenge ever set
in the first week
of The Great British Bake Off.
I would remind the bakers
that what we don't want is style
over substance.
Of course we want it to look like
what it's not,
it's an illusion cake.
But it's also got
to taste fantastic.
These guys have got to be
not just bakers but true artists,
and probably a little bit of
engineering as well,
and I imagine they've had a few
sleepless nights over this one.
Nerves don't exist today,
so I've got to smash it,
irrelevant of how I feel.
I want it to be airy, I really don't
want negative feedback today.
I don't want you filming it,
it's split!
It changes the rise.
Actually, the denser the mixture for
this, the better,
because I need a lot
of structural integrity.
Sophie's dense sponge
will be flavoured with chocolate
and carved into the shape
of a champagne bucket,
complete with sugar work ice cubes
and a chocolate champagne bottle.
It's actually a cake I did
for my housemate, for her birthday.
When I took it to the bar,
the bouncer went,
"You can't take in
your own alcohol."
And I was like, "It must look good,
then, if I can trick the bouncer!"
And Sophie isn't the only one
heading for a posh night out.
I like going out in the evening
and getting dressed up sometimes.
Rarely, but when I do,
I quite like a nice bag.
Stacey's making red velvet chocolate
sponge,
which she'll decorate to look
like a designer clutch handbag.
It's quite a wet mix, isn't it?
Yes. It's going to be quite moist.
It's got buttermilk,
a little red wine vinegar, oil.
When you add the moisture
to a sponge,
it becomes quite airy and
can collapse very, very easily.
I've done it quite a few times, and
I'm hoping that it won't collapse.
Thank you.  Good luck.
Looking forward to the moist clutch.
OK!
As Stacey and Sophie head out...
..Tom is looking forward
to a quiet night in.
I am baking a stack of books,
the idea being a relaxing evening
by the fire.
The sponge inside Tom's books
will be flavoured
with two of the classics.
My flavours are
lemon and poppy seed.
I think it can pack quite a punch.
Whether you've had a quiet night in
or a big night out...
..the flavours in James' sponge
should get you up in the morning.
Got espresso coffee in it.
I start off most mornings
in the office
with a cup of coffee
and a croissant.
James will carve
his espresso coffee cake
into the shape of
his favourite breakfast.
It is kind of my day-to-day life
and then my baking life,
which is totally separate,
so this kind of joins the two.
So, I'm making
the banana sponge now.
Liam's flavoured sponge will also
be transformed into breakfast.
Every Sunday,
I try to have pancakes.
Me and my mum prefer
the thick American style.
His banana sponge
with blueberry compote
will be disguised as a stack
of pancakes,
complete with his mum's favourite
trimmings.
What's this for, then? The granola?
Because I always have granola
with my pancakes.
I just think the flavour's better.
Like you guys said,
I have to work on my flavours.
How are you making the pancakes?
So I'm making a marshmallow fondant
and then I'm going to roll it into,
like, a sausage shape,
and then cut out, like, thin strips
and then wrap it round.
Why would you roll it round
the cake?
That's how it will look like
pancakes.
Trust me, Paul.
PRUE LAUGHS
For Chris and Flo's sponges...
That's not red enough.
..colour is crucial to pulling off
their illusions.
What did you base the recipe on?
Paul's pork and egg pie recipe.
Oh, it's his own sort of
savoury recipe?
Yeah, so I'm making a yellow
sponge to represent the yolk,
I've got some white sponge to create
the egg,
then I'm going to make the pork.
Chris will have to cut and place his
almond-flavoured coloured sponges
so that when it's sliced, his cake
will look like Paul's favourite pie.
I know you're an analytical kind
of guy.
How precise has this all
to be measured?
Down to the millimetre.
Do you feel you need this one
to get yourself a bit higher up
the rankings?
I think we do, yes.
We? It's a "we" now, is it?! It is.
I like that.
I thought this was a team!
You'd told me,
you told me you're getting them
drunk for me.
Did you give them that money
I gave you?
Flo's coloured sponge
should create an illusion
that's a little less savoury.
My husband loved melon.
We went abroad one time
and the barman made us
a watermelon cocktail,
called One In A Melon,
so it just brings happy memories.
I don't like melon myself.
Flo's red sponge will be soaked
in melon syrup,
studded with chocolate chips
and covered in green fondant.
I'm going in.
I'm going to have to do them
on two shelves today,
and I normally like to keep them all
on the same shelf.
With the multiple sponges required
to build the illusions...
Beautiful!
..come multiple baking times.
Start at 20.
And whilst keeping track of that...
That'll be in for
about 13 to 15 minutes.
..they also need to find time to
make multiple decorative elements
to deceive the eye.
Here we've got the ice malts.
It's basically a type of sugar.
It melts down to be totally clear,
and that's going to go
into my ice cube trays.
It mimics the look of the ice cube.
For her sugar-based deception,
Kate is also working with
unconventional materials.
This looks surprisingly
like Glacier Mints.
Yeah, I'm making a terrarium cake.
A terrarium is a small glass
container that you put plants in.
Mini greenhouse.  I used to collect
cactuses when I was a kid.
Kate's panes of Glacier Mint glass
will enclose buttercream
house plants
on a chocolate
and star anise sponge.
It's about engineering,
cos you've got to make sure all
those pieces fit together.
I've designed the moulds with a bit
of a lip on them,
so structurally
they've got some support.
Have you done this whole thing
before?
Not all together, no. I've done it
in different elements.
I think we ought to let you get
on with it. It's terrifying!
Peter is also venturing into the
intimidating world of molten sugar.
I made the knife mould myself,
so the ultimate goal is to have
a knife that is cutting
through the bread.
Peter's knife will cut a lemon
Madeira cake loaf
sat on a Genoese sponge
chopping board.
It just represents my foray
into baking,
cos I started baking bread
before anything else.
Stephen's also attempting to make
bread in cake week.
Being one of 12 bakers, I thought,
why not make a lunch for us
out of cake?
He is preparing 2kg of fondant
for his bakers' lunch...
to cover a loaf of chocolate
and hazelnut sponge
that will be sliced for
an accompanying fondant-filled
sandwich.
Which is a bacon,
lettuce and tomato.
BLT?  BLT.
How are you going to make that?
I will use this bad boy.
This is a spray gun
for edible colour.
For bits of lettuce, tomato, bacon.
Perfect.  Nice idea.
I think that's very interesting.
Good luck.  Thank you.
When it comes to fondant food, Yan's
lunch is a little more adventurous.
It's a pasta machine.
My mum's been trying to get rid
of it to me,
cos her house is massive and
mine is tiny, so why wouldn't she?
She'll attempt to make fondant
noodles
to top a banana cake
transformed into
a bowl of Japanese ramen,
complete with fondant Pak Choi
and chicken katsu fillet.
I like noodles, so banana ramen
just rolls off the tongue.
Yes, beauty.
Bakers, unfortunately,
time is not an illusion.  OK.
You are halfway through
your Showstopper Challenge.
Very happy with those.
We can work with that.
Bingo.
While some are happy with the
sponges
they'll have to build with...
Zen.
..for Stacey...
there seems to be
a pattern emerging.
Usually, they're much higher,
and I wanted a light sponge,
and that is not a light sponge.
Am I going to put it in the bin?
Yeah.
I want to redo my sponge.
Not what I wanted today, so...
For the rest of the bakers...
..it's the point of no return.
The sheer complexity of this year's
first show-stopping designs...
Cutting a cake when it's warm,
sometimes it springs back on you.
..means precision in every cut,
in every cake, is crucial.
This is going to be the core
of the cup.
I'm now making the inside,
so this is going to be my egg,
I'm going to cover it up, job done.
And breathe.
Julia has also planned an illusion
on the inside of her Showstopper.
I'm making a Russian doll.
I think it's quite self-explanatory.
Hidden at the heart
of Julia's Showstopper
will be a fondant and sponge doll,
surrounded by a larger doll
made with five layers
of classic Victorian sponge.
The outside looks Russian, like me,
and the inside is English,
which is also me now.
How long have we got?  About an hour.
An hour?
Doable.
Very happy I re-did it.
Getting somewhere now.
Carving it round, like a melon.
I'm making the doll for the inside.
Now I'm doing three things at the
same time - sugar, fondant, cake.
Four things - icing.
The whole thing.
The clock seems to get faster.
Just about to do serious cuttage.
Shall we do it together?
It's like a wedding.
Feels lovely, darling.
Ooh.  Ooh?
Don't worry.  Is it OK?
It's technically your fault, but...
Yeah.
I want to try and get it
all neatly covered in one go,
and then I can trim it back after.
I'm just piping the succulents on,
although I think the buttercream
might be a little bit too hard.
My hand is so shaky!
I'm just trying to do
a crumb coating.
That's the diameter of the cake,
or circumference, I don't know.
I can't remember the last time
I did maths.
This doesn't look anything like
I want it to.
It's a katsu chicken fillet.
It's made out of Rice Krispies
and marshmallows.
I'm just dropping it in.
It's like, you know when pancakes
have those air bubbles,
so like just over there.
Bakers, you have half an hour
to bedeck your breathtaking bakes
of beauty.
Still redeemable.
Everything's redeemable.
Yes.  You can do this.
This is modelling chocolate.
Wow, what's happening now?
You should have seen it
before I started sculpting!
So this is the top
of my champagne bottle.
Oh, yeah! OK, well, good luck with
that, yeah.  Thanks very much.
I'm glad I saw that.
Using my science background
to create the salmon roe.
So I've liquefied some agar in some
mango juice and then obviously you
want the spherical balls,
and how do you create that?
So I've cooled down some oil in the
fridge, and as I pipe in the liquid,
it cools down and creates
the outer wall.
Juice balls.
Science!
Does it look like a watermelon?
How long have we got? How long?
Five minutes until we see
what your cakes are made of.
Or what they're not made of.
I haven't really got time.
Try to not get in a state.
Do you put bacon on first
or lettuce?
We'll put lettuce on first.
Let's not be monsters about this.
Ten...  Carrot.
Nine.  Eight.
Seven.  Six.
Five.  Four.
Three.  There we go.
Two.
One.  Bakers, your time is up.
Put down your illusions.
What a disaster.
No more touching your illusions.
No.
Well done.
It's judgment time for
the show-stopping illusion cakes.
Yan, please bring up
your illusion cake.
I think what you've produced there
is a work of art.
I love the way you've
used the Rice Krispies
and then the eggs look incredible.
PRUE:  The little salmon roe,
it'll taste like mango,
and your brain is
telling you one thing
and your taste buds
are telling you another.
We should be eating it
with chopsticks!  I know.
Look at that. Isn't that beautiful?
I think it's got
a good banana flavour.
The case is slightly too dry.
It's unfortunate,
but that design is incredible.
I think you could have
done more with it.
It's not detailed enough.
Yeah.
I love the flavour.
I think it's a little dry.
It so nearly worked, didn't it?
That glass looks great. It's such
a shame you lost it at the top.
Yeah.
Texture's nice. Very moist.
Nice flavour. I like it.
It's collapsed a bit there,
hasn't it?
It did. It needed more time
before I iced it.
Mm. Very nice flavour.
It's a bit dry, but the chocolate,
the coffee, is delicious.
It's a little bit basic
on the outside.  Sure.
This is so exciting!
Oh, that's disappointing.
We can see it.
Oh, that's brilliant, that bit.
LAUGHTER
Very almondy flavour.
But it comes down to the texture.
It's a little bit too dense for me.
Flo, please bring up
your illusion cake.
PRUE:  If you saw that in
the greengrocer's shop,
you would think it was a watermelon.
I'm dying to see
what it looks like inside.
Oh, there you go!
Look at that.
NOEL:  Wowsers.
That's excellent, there.
Now, this has got watermelon syrup
in here as well, hasn't it?  Yeah.
I want some with the chocolate in.
I can't really get the watermelon,
but then my mouth
is full of chocolate.
What's the matter with that?
I think it's wonderful.
Your sponge is spot-on.
I love the colour you got inside
and the chocolate just
highlights it and lifts it up.
I love you, Flo.  I love you too now!
SHE LAUGHS
It's the fattest Russian doll
I've ever seen.
Proper Siberian!
Is that right? OK!
LAUGHTER
Oh, look at that!
NOEL APPLAUDS
Right, let's see if
we can cut into her.
I find the cake a little bit plain
and a little bit dry.
It's a little bit simplistic.
I think it's a pity about the knife.
A bit dry.
The flavour in there is beautiful.
I just think you've left it in there
a little bit too long.
I'm not certain that
I would know it was a handbag.
It looks like a decorated cake
rather than a handbag.
But what's more important is,
is it a great cake?
I think it's delicious.  Thank you.
Certainly a bit sticky
in your mouth.
You wouldn't want to eat
a lot of it because it's so rich.
The sponge is delicious.
What throws you is the colour.
Overall, not really
overwhelmed by the design.
I have to say, the champagne bottle
looks amazing.
It's really beautifully done.
Oh!
I'll just get that before it melts!
Surprisingly dry.
OK.  The ganache is
making it even drier,
but the flavour of
the chocolate's nice.
Steven, please bring up
your illusion cake.
Wow.
That is stunning.
Without a shadow of a doubt,
you know exactly what that is.
Absolutely astonishing.
You wouldn't think that
wasn't bread, would you?
It is a chocolate hazelnut sponge
with a peanut butter frosting.
It's perfect.
The hazelnut, the peanut,
the frosting,
the layers are equal, the outside,
the colour, the texture,
it's all there.
And it's not too sweet.
I think it's lovely.  Well done.
Well done.  Thank you.
Well done.
Liam, please bring up
your illusion cake.
Well, I have to say,
I think it looks delicious.
It makes my mouth water.
I want to come to yours
for breakfast.
Any time.  It just...
It's so lovely!
LAUGHTER
I mean, it really is
very difficult to believe
that that's not pancakes.
Yeah, I think it's ingenious, but...
it's got to taste good as well.
There's a lot going on in here
as well, isn't there?  Yeah.
I was expecting
more banana flavour.
I think that's because
the blueberries overpower it.
Yeah.  But it's delicious.
A mouthful is lovely.  OK.
I think your banana cake
is beautiful.
Well done, mate.  Thank you.
Oh, good.
HE EXHALES
NOEL:  Paul and Prue must now decide
who'll be our first Star Baker
and who'll be the first to leave
the Bake Off tent.
The standard has been
ridiculously high, hasn't it?
I think this is one of
the strongest challenges I've seen
for the first programme.
So, who has stood out?
Well, I think Flo came straight back
with a cracking good watermelon.
Sophie has been very constant.
Steven didn't fail us
on the Showstopper.
Nobody wants to be the first person
to leave, but who is in some danger?
Liam saved himself with that
Showstopper. It was stunning.
Stacey, I think, is in trouble.
This didn't look like a handbag.
Peter hasn't done well.
Chris is full of good ideas.
His flavours are spectacular,
but his baking falls short.
Well, I have to say, none of it
sounds straightforward.
We have to send
somebody away, don't we?
You could send Noel.  I'll go.
I'll go now, actually.
I'll take a hit for the team!
THEY LAUGH
It's been great.
I've loved working with you guys!
Nice to meet you.
Sandi will be fine.
Bye.  Bye, darling.
See you later, kids.
Bakers, it is my tremendous
privilege to announce
the very first Star Baker.
The Star Baker is the person
whose Showstopper was honestly
the best thing since sliced bread.
LAUGHTER
The Star Baker is Steven.
APPLAUSE
Oh, bakers, sadly
I have to deliver the bad news.
Horrible job. The person that
we have to say goodbye to is...
..Peter.
I'm sorry, mate.
Give us a hug, come on.
Well done.
Peter, you were great,
I hope you've enjoyed it.  Yes.
It's been a wonderful
experience.
Maybe I could have done things
differently,
but it's been just a pleasure
meeting everyone.
PRUE:  I'm really sorry to
say goodbye to Peter.
He was up against real competition.
Sorry, buddy.
The standard this year is so high,
and unfortunately,
it was Peter's turn.
I don't know what to say, mate.
It's all right.
I understand it was the flavours
that put me a whisker above Peter.
Give us a bit of love, then.
Hugely stressful and fun, and
I've made some great friends.
Thank you so much.
And I'm so pleased they gave me the
opportunity to hopefully improve.
When I seen that bread, I went...
When I got that feedback today,
I was ecstatic.
The kids will be absolutely
thrilled to bits.
I won't be telling them anything
that they don't know.
It's me that doubts myself.
PHONE RINGS
Hello, darling.
Hello, Ma, are you all right?
I made Star Baker.
GASPS
No!
And, Paul shook my hand.
Oh, darling, I'm so proud of you!
I just want to feel like this
all the time.
Not crying, obviously.
That's quite awkward, on the tube.
Next time...
it's biscuits.
That's it.
GRUNTING
With an emotional
signature challenge.
Am I going to be crying when I
eat your biscuits?  I hope not.
An oriental technical...
You've got to be really...
..that may predict
the Bakers' futures.
So frustrating!
And, a Bake Off first.
This is insane.
Spectacular show-stopping
biscuits.
This is probably the hardest thing
I've ever done in my life.
That are good enough to eat.
It's a little masterpiece.
And to play.
Ah...
SHE EXHALES
Subtitles by Ericsson